all right we reached out to the teacher
in that video as well as the school he
works for they haven't got back to us
here with the reaction fox news
contributors laura trump leo 2.0 terrell
laura call me old-fashioned we pay more
per capita per student than any other
industrialized country we have the worst
results for our money you know anywhere
between 37th and 40th how about we stick
with reading writing math science and
computers and let the parents uh teach
the values at home or they can have an
opt-in
extracurricular class after school is
over how's that
well i don't think that people would
call it old-fashioned sean i think
that's just common sense i mean our kids
are falling below just basic
requirements um in education we're
falling behind so many other countries
at this point you're exactly right why
aren't we focusing on the core things
that are going to help them in their
future lives look our children are the
most precious and innocent segment of
our society and as parents it is our job
to protect them
at all costs and gosh you see videos
like the one you just saw
you see all these people out there
trying to push ideas on our kids that
they have no ability sean in first grade
in kindergarten to even understand and
especially that one in boston i mean i
don't understand this this is an
educator not even teaching facts not
even teaching science that a doctor
makes a guess as to what a baby is
whenever it's born whether it's a boy or
a girl that is absolutely ridiculous but
it is incredibly frightening right now
to be a parent in america because gosh
we we have so much of the evidence of
this all across our country and i think
back to when i was growing up i was the
only girl
in my entire neighborhood so i got to
play with all the boys but it also made
me enjoy the games that boys played and
kind of dress like a boy who could have
considered me a tomboy and sometimes i
think man if i had been born 30 years
later would i have had teachers trying
to convince me that perhaps i should
have been a boy maybe i was misgendered
in some
variety or some sort it is honestly kind
of terrifying there is one thing for
sure if we continue down this path we
are looking down the barrel of one
incredibly confused generation of
americans coming up right now it's
insane
how about we let the parents teach these
things to our kids leo i don't think
that's complicated
this is very very scary
sean everything laura said everything
you said the video this is frightening
this is just as important as the issue
of crime the issue of inflation our kids
are in jeopardy you have an extremist
sean i'm a schoolteacher i still have my
license and i'll tell you right now you
have an extremist group trying to
indoctrinate these kids they're they're
saying we don't care about english math
and history we want to transform these
kids and take them away from the family
unit and i'm telling every family who's
watching this program go into those
classrooms and look at the lesson plans
look at the core curriculum because you
need to know what's being taught in
these classes and i'll tell you sean the
red wave on the national level we need a
red wave with the local school district
they are taking they're trying to take
our kids away from the family unit and
it's frightening and it's dangerous
leo 2.0 thank you laura trump thank you
scary times unbelievable hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else